on parle un petit peu de discrimination
positive alors après sciences po l'ena
mais aussi polytechnique ou normale sup
doivent-elles se mettre à cette
discrimination positive le sujet il est
sur la table depuis que le président de
la république qu'elle lançait l'idée de
supprimer en tout cas dans sa forme
actuelle l'ena et qu'il a dit qu'il
fallait revenir à un modèle plus
méritocratique comme on va l'entendre
dans un instant on en parle parce que le
figaro et vous pourrez aller plus loin
en lisant ces pages événement demain on
en parle tout de suite mais donc je vous
propose d'abord d'écouter le président
de la république évoqué le sujet je suis
profondément attachée au modèle
méritocratique un élitisme républicain
qui fait qu' on attire dans l'état les
meilleurs pour pouvoir régler les
problèmes les plus complexes
néanmoins des changements sont à faire
en termes de recrutement d'abord est ce
que notre haute fonction publique
ressemble à la société que nous sommes
non c'est pas vrai elle ne lui ressemble
pas il faut s'interroger nos modes de
recrutement créer un billet alors
laurent bouvet je vous entend réagir le
sonore n'est même pas terminée que vous
dites la société n'a pas à ressembler à
la haute fonction publique n'a pas reçu
rejet a lancé me régale ses président de
la république il n'est pas le premier à
le dire c'est pas lui en particuier peu
importe mais c'est ces gens d'abord de
l'élite
mardi on est un éminent qui expliquent
toujours que l'élite a failli que
l'élite ça ne va pas qu'elle ait pas
bien recruter qu'elles ressentent pas la
société etc
mais d'abord une élite ils venaient dire
avant quelque chose qui est strictement
contradictoires il venait de rappeler
son attachement au principe
méritocratique qui n'a rien à voir avec
le fait qu'une élite
je définis pas là on dit une élite où
tout le monde voit bien de quoi il est
question
ça ça demanderait beaucoup de précision
du peu importe on va vite une élite n'a
pas à ressembler et ressembler commencer
quoi ressemble et comment socialement
ressembler du point de vue de la
diversité comme on dit pudiquement
ressembler du point de vue
de l'origine territoriale et
géographique qu'est ce qu'elle écrit
sana ça n'a pas de sens si on est pour
le mérite
si on est pour un système et les système
méritocratique ont leurs défauts
on pourra préciser ils ont leurs défauts
mais quand on dit qu'on est pour le
système du mérite républicain classique
système des concours d'accès à la
fonction publique système des grandes
écoles etc et bien dans ce cas on ne
peut pas à la fois dire qu'on est pour
que les lits pour que ceux qui passent
le filtre par leur travail il faut que
chacun puisse y accéder c'est plutôt
comme ça qu'il aurait dû le dire il faut
que ça ressemble à la société ça n'a pas
de sens et scapa matière quand même à
corriger quelque chose quand on sait
alors je cite quelques chiffres karine
valentin l'enquêté pisa 2016 un enfant
dont les parents sont diplômés du
supérieur à 14 fois plus de chances
d'être lui-même diplômé je vous passe
les chiffres aussi sur l'origine sociale
des élèves de polytechnique ou de l'x
qu'ils sont
dix enfants de cadres 50 fois plus que
des enfants d'ouvriers
tous ces chiffres sont largement connues
on dit est-ce qu'il faut pas sur 10
souvent si on ne fait rien ne changera
alors premièrement ça dépend pas d'un
mois la discrimination positive le
principe même me heurte c'est la
justification de la justice est
insupportable même moi je veux dire en
tant que femme j'ai pu dans certaines
circonstances on a pu me proposait de
bénéficier d'une sorte de discrimination
positive que j'ai trouvé profondément
insultant entre en fait par ailleurs sur
quels critères et discrimination
positive alors que bien souvent ces
techniques mais pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que ça serait pas différent il ya déjà
plein de d'escrimé bien l'esprit clair
voire pas de mise en place par sciences
po que je suis certain que les critères
des territoriales exemple ouvre en fait
des réalités sociales sociales qui sont
en même temps en france c'est très
particulier dans ces quartiers qui sont
aussi des ré des réalités de l'origine
voilà et qu'on appelle la discrimination
sont les handicapés sur les gens qui
sont gros sûr il ya plein de
discrimination est en fait ici une fois
une diversité il faut une diversité de
caractère et phonique la cité de
compétences il faut ni la cité de
qualité je vois pas en quoi le critère
de l'origine ethnique culturelle
d'autres changent rien écrite et non pas
ça c'est qu'il faut réfléchir on va
aller ça répond déjà mathieu et marie
sur l'idée est ce qu'il faut en faire un
petit peu ce qu'il faut faire
différemment
battu il ya deux choses
je crois que veut pas laisser la
situation telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui parce que vous parliez de la
crise des gilets jaunes ont fait qu'il
ya une critique fondamentale de l'élite
qui est justifiée qui est injustifiée
avec des excès dans tous les sens mais
c'est élite effectivement ne ressemble
pas ou pas assez où les gens ne les gens
n'adhèrent plus à cette élite c'est pas
moi une question de ressemblance c'est
d'adhésion c'est parce qu'ils ne peuvent
plus y accéder vous pouvez alors c'est
différent
s'il ne parle de ressemblance on est
d'accord ils ne peuvent payer en partie
au sentiment de ces blocs et leurs
enfants
il n'ya plus cher
nice n'a pas servi leur intérêt a dit
cela ne s'est pas préoccupé de l'élite a
fait remiser a fermé les écoutilles à
partir d'un certain moment notamment
quand les conditions de la compétition
mondiale entre les élites s'est durcie
l'élite a fermé les écoutilles par
rapport aux vieillit que représentait le
vivier méritocratique ça s'est passé de
cette manière en france et oui oui oui
mais quand on regarde les chiffres sur
les 50 dernières années on s'aperçoit
est là la reproduction de cette de
satellites continue et continue c'est à
dire qu'il n'y avait pas beaucoup plus
d'enfants issus de milieux défavorisés
c'est alors j'ai regardé tous les
chiffres à retenir ça dépend si vous
prenez telle école sur tel trajet annuel
mais coulibaly n'a pas ce que je me bats
les habituels rds les nile d'ailleurs
son directeur actuel le dis comme devait
le dire madame oiseaux quand elles
l'étaient les n'a été plus mixtes
il ya vingt ans et où j'arrive des plus
minimes mais ça veut pas dire si je me
permets en scarlett doit être
relativisée tout de suite parce que 15%
de 50 % d'ouvriers c'est équivalent
probablement aujourd'hui à 6 ou 7 % de
17% donc là sept aps la société
française a changé donc il faut comparer
les chiffres de l'hiver
mais cette situation là aujourd'hui qui
était quelque part je crois accepté
tolérée elle est de moins en moins parce
qu'on al'impression effectivement que
les élites se sont totalement coupés du
reste de la société
donc il faut répondre à ça il faut
répondre à ça est-ce que la réponse et
la discrimination positive
moi je ne crois pas je ne crois pas
parce que je pense que là on passe dans
un tout autre système qui n'est pas le
nôtre qui n'est pas notre système
républicain tout simplement
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut
quand même qu'on sort ou est ce qu'on
met en place sinon pour voir qu'un qui a
été fait pour voir ce qui a été fait
alors on à part on parler de sciences po
tout à l'heure on parlait de cette
discrimination qui s'est fait à partir
des aides donc des quartiers qui étaient
quand même une façon de faire un peu de
la discrimination positive à la
française sans atteindre au principe
constitutionnel pour faire simple est ce
que c'est la piste j'en sais rien moi je
continue à croire mais
c'est quelqu'un de gauche qui parle que
s'il ya discrimination
c'est une discrimination d'abord sociale
et que c'est plus probablement à partir
de ce tropisme qu'il faut partir et pas
une discrimination ethnique parce que
c'est pas du même nom mais morne et et
je crois que cela correspond plus à
notre modèle républicain
mais il faut le faire il faut le faire
il faut sérieusement il faut pas faire
l'habillage est ce que emmanuel macron a
réellement de l' envie de le faire en
tout cas on peut les reconnaître que
quand même il bouleverse les grands
corps ce qui n'est pas rien quand on
connaît la puissance de deux de ses
antécédents corps je vous laisse
réfléchir encore quelques instants mari
on donne les réponses de nos internautes
à la question générale êtes vous
favorable aux politiques de
discrimination positive dans les grandes
écoles pour accentuer la diversité 74%
d'entre vous ils sont défavorables donc
les trois quarts r34 nous dit la seule
discrimination acceptable et celle du
mérite
tout le reste n'est que copinage ou
stratégie électorale nicole elle est
totalement opposé nous dit elle on doit
être acceptée pour ses compétences et
pas d'où on vient et babineau je suis
d'accord avec macron c'est un constat et
le gouvernement doit intervenir pour ce
type de problématique
marie c'est vrai que je prends le sujet
un petit peu différemment l'origine
sociale en effet discriminant sur
l'accès aux grandes écoles dont on parle
tout à l'heure mais aussi au niveau de
vie est là on rejoint tout le débat qui
est qui se tient en ce moment c'est un
des freins aussi celle des freins c'est
un des francs à s'élever
économiquement dans la société c'est à
dire que parmi les 10 % des français les
plus modestes c'est la moitié sont des
enfants d'ouvriers et al'inverse ils ne
sont que 17 % d'enfants d'ouvriers a
accédé au niveau de revenus les plus
élevés si on ne sait si on change rien
ça restera comme ça alors ses tartes à
la crème de dire qu'il faut mieux être
enfant de médecins ou que fils d'employé
de ménage mais le fait est que si on ne
fait rien ça reste comme ça et
économiquement ces gens ces gens là ne
vont pas s'en sortir mais on est tous
d'accord pour dire qu'il faut faire
quelque chose contre ça mais elle que
les abominations positive
rien n'est moins sûr alors est ce que le
bon système c'est celui que met en place
je crois les sexes qui est lâché c'est
sans doute et des classes préparatoires
qui sont alors on va passer de la
discrimination positive ce qu'est le
recrutement dans la classe préparatoire
il va bien falloir ça y est de 20 des
quelque chose il ya le il ya les deux
systèmes concurrents les deux grands
systèmes que ses suites sciences po et
qui suit de l'essai qui sont les deux
modèles qui sont apparues à la fin des
années 90 au début des années 2000 qui
se sont heurtés de front dans la manière
de faire
le système de sciences po c'est que vous
faites des accords avec des lycées en
zone d'éducation qu'on appelait avant
les zones d'éducation prioritaire et les
élèves venant de ces lycées qui sont
sélectionnés par leurs professeurs de la
correction ne passe pas le congo normale
à l'essec ont fait est qu'elle
renforcement dans des zones d'éducation
prioritaire pour les élèves qui veulent
qu'ils disent vouloir passer le concours
et ont fait du renfort scolaire et du
renfort aussi culture qu'on appelle cole
culture à dire qu'on les emmène au musée
au théâtre etc pour avoir une sorte de
fer en divers lieux culturels d'habitude
a créé un habitus différents voilà donc
ça ça ces deux modèles
mais ce ces deux modèles sont des
modèles sont des rustines en fait c'est
ça la question c'est que ce sont des
rustines d'abord s'est limité aux zones
d'éducation prioritaire qui n'épuise pas
le sujet des différences sociales et de
l'accès de la mobilité sociale vous avez
énormément d'enfants qui ne sont pas en
zone d'éducation prioritaire et qui
n'ont pas accédé dès lors à ce type de
concours ou de facilité il ya eu des
livres récents sur le sujet sur les
haies alors vers les faits les faits un
des effets pervers c'est que des des
enfants de classes moyennes moyennes
plus se sont inscrits dans ces lycées
exact pour passer ce qui est trop
difficile donc ça c'est un premier pas
la méritocratie le système du mérite
républicain c'est un système qu'il faut
nourrir si vous voulez c'est comme une
chaudière dans laquelle il faut mettre
du carburant
si vous fermez la chaudière c'est un
système qui s'épuise et il n'y a plus de
personnes qui peut y accéder
le problème c'est un problème d'accès
est une des mesures beaucoup plus
efficace que la discrimination positive
c'est ce qu'a fait jean michel blanquer
en dédoublant les classes des classes de
cp et en ligne mais sans aller en
diminuant le nombre d'enfants arborant
un chaudière il commence dès les
derniers eurent le mérite c'est pas si
vous vous laissez pas de de dire à
certains si vous représentez la société
comme une pyramide pour accès pour
accéder en aussi vous voulez a avec des
goulets d'étranglement etc c'est pas de
dire à certains certains vous vous aurez
une sorte de privilège vous venez d'un
milieu aisé vous avez été dans les bons
lycées etc
vous avez une sorte de pass à vie pour
pouvoir accéder à ce type d'école et
ensuite aux carrières et aux niveaux de
vie qui vont avec
et puis on va vous rajouter une petite
porte sur le côté pour la diversité de
la société voyez diversité sociale de
couleurs etc
et là ça va permettre de s'acheter à bon
compte pour les consciences une bonne
conscience
non le mérite c'est de dire à tout le
monde vous êtes des citoyens
vous avez le droit et vos enfants le
droit parce qu'ils vont travailler parce
que vous allez vous sacrifiez parce
qu'elle est maman pour les âges
ils ont le droit d'accéder à une autre
sissoko dira est apte et on fait des
grands discours dans quand il fait
depuis des années nous on l'a fait on se
croit que ces 2011 avec richard
descoings et sa marge d'une certaine
façon on savait que la réalité est
façonné sa marche rien alors j'ai pas
des chiffres précis mais ça mal à l'aise
hier c'était social est allé lui-même 6
7 6 6 1 des chicots de l'agression comme
le nombre de non non non non
comme le nombre d'élèves 10% des
inscrits comme les ans comme le nombre
d'élèves de sciences po a été multiplié
par 4 je crois de mémoire d' entre 2000
et aujourd'hui à vérifier vous avez
effectivement eu une possibilité pour
l'accès large istres 1-2 gens qui
viennent des zones d'éducation
prioritaire ce qui n'existait pas dans
l'est jusqu'aux années 90 c'est tout ce
que ça veut dire
après tant mieux pour ces jeunes moi
j'ai enseigné 15 ans à sciences po avant
et après la réforme
tant mieux pour ces jeunes et ces jeunes
d'ailleurs il y avait très peu de
différence finalement avec les autres
élèves et ça permet de créer une forme
de d'esprit commun et c'est tant mieux
pour eux le problème c'est pas pour ces
jeunes en particulier en se disant bon
on en a sauvé quelques années le premier
en place de systèmes et si on est
attaché aux mairies et on fait du mérite
si on veut plus faire de mérite on
considère que la république le mérite
républicain tout ça c'est des
vieilleries c'est les barbes blanches de
ferdinand buisson et c'est du 19e siècle
eh bien on arrête et on fait un système
à l'américaine où vous avez de la
discrimination positive et les drm aussi
mais vous allez payer vos études très
cher et vous allez vous endetter pour
payer vos études américaines reviennent
sur la discrimination positive
d'ailleurs ils ont appris les effets
pervers et on a vu les usages 7e place
avec preuves dans les univers ce moment
il ya des contentieux très important
aussi caresse maintenant moi je donne
mathieu mais terminer sur le sujet
il ya une différence entre ce qui s'est
fait en france à ma connaissance c'est
ce qui se fait aux états unis et d'où
d'ailleurs les contentieux qui sont en
cours c'est que en particulier à
sciences po ça a été possible vous le
rappeliez parce qu il y ait plus
d'étudiants c'est là que ça pas été des
étudiants prix à la place des autres
dans les pays dans cette pratique est
quand même la source principale de
contentieux c'est à dire pour thiers
simple des étudiants blancs qui disent
moi j'ai été brûlées favorisés par
rapport à un étudiant aujourd'hui par
année par rapport à des étudiants noirs
ou par rapport à des dons d'une autre
ethnie donc ses sabres ont été
défavorisés par le système
je vous renvoie des articles sur le
sujet sur le blog de michèle tribalat
est banalement ce qu'ils veulent de
michèle tribalat